Along the way, you've picked up some useful tools for model building and
data analysis.
We've gained some insight in how the amount of data relates to
accuracy in our models.
We've learned to look for structure in our data.
Sometimes, there is no functional relationship in data and
what you're seeing is the simple result of a random process.
In which case,
the best performing model we can come up with is a fit to that process.
We've seen how to identify non-linear relationships between variables.
Sometimes, these relationships cannot be picked up by linear model tools,
such as linear regression.
We've seen that information gain is a more general and powerful tool for
identifying relationships.
And finally, we've learned how to quantity and
communicate the uncertainty in our model using confidence bands.